sir Andrew Cuomo Andrew Cuomo blasts
Biden over migrant crisis Andrew
chromoblast Biden after migrant crisis
and Andrew's going to be missing for a
minute he had lunch one time with Kelly
and Connor everybody talked about it now
he is back Andrew Cuomo former New York
Governor criticized President Biden open
board and policy calling it a mistake
and unprepared in the latest episode of
his podcast matter of fact Cuomo stated
it was a mistake for President Biden to
open the Border without having a plan to
handle the tremendous flow of people
Cuomo also accused the Biden
administration of not understanding the
consequences of enacting their promises
and said the southern states were right
that opening the Border created a
tremendous hardship for them to handle
they were right that the federal
government was not prepared Cuomo also
spoke on the uncontrolled flow of
migrants
and its impact saying the border is not
just a Gateway for people but for drugs
this is on top of a homeless problem
that has already strained resources in
urban areas my one question if it's not
for when we talked about this especially
when Roland was here too if it's not for
the votes and we're not talking about
these people I'm talking about their
kids kids down the line they're all
going to vote Democrat because I'm I'm
pretty sure they're going to be the ones
that say listen we had the Border open
remember to vote for us if it's not that
what is it because don't try to tell me
that this Administration cares about
minorities or they they do not care what
is their actual motive if it isn't that
patent if it's not the votes because
it's not oh we love immigration it's the
Statue of Liberty is a symbol and we or
oh no no it's not that what is it what
it would if you had to guess not it not
being the votes what else if you were a
Democrat what would you what would be
your defense what's first of all it's
Optics if you remember do you remember
the AOC picture at the border yeah can
you go to the picture of AOC emotional
emotional crying posting it it does it
was a photo shoot it was a photo it's a
photo showed a picture of her crying
yeah you know and what it looked like
and she's at the border yeah and that
was to trash Trump of course okay has
she been back there taking similar
pictures under these no of course she's
not okay so this is called politics this
is the dirty side of politics some are
better than others she's one of the best
she's probably in the top 10 best you
know gamification dirty politics
manipulation she's won the best she
wouldn't have 30 million followers on
Twitter if she was a lover or hater she
plays she's like Patrick Beverly she's
like Ron artes she's like these players
that would know how to throw the elbow
and piss you off Chris Paul how annoying
of a point guard he is to get the foul
and flop and all that stuff that's the
Optics okay you either can do it or you
cannot do it she's one of them okay now
on the other side with long-term voting
first of all if you or close if you
leave the Border open
who are they coming to see anyways
they're coming to see who the the who
the people that are cross on the border
who are they coming to see other family
members okay so you're winning whose
votes their kids and their kids you're
winning people's votes who are already
living here's families coming today very
true so that is a vote that you want
okay so then the people that are coming
in who are you winning future voters is
what you're saying okay great but it's
such a major issue that if you don't go
and talk about it the media is not
talking about it the left doesn't have
to talk about it mainstream media
doesn't have to talk about it however
the problem today is the following the
problem they're going to face today is
the left itself is done with Kamala and
with Biden did you see the story about
what Hillary Clinton said about Kamala
Harris two days ago just read that story
or no what'd you say have you seen this
word circulating ever so Hillary Clinton
is on this tour going all these places
in India India's her new Haiti by the
way just so you guys know oh [__] really
the next Target for her is Haiti she got
money from Haiti the next Target for her
is India if she targeted Haiti remember
how much money they got from Haiti and
the money never ended up going to the
actual people well now she started
getting India next she's been in India
this past week going around oh my God
here's what's going on climate change is
really hurting you it's getting hotter
and stuff all these strange comments
she's making but this is what happened
this week about her comments regarding
Kamala Harris top Democrats are
questioning vice president Kamala
Harris's leadership abilities and former
Secretary of State Hillary Clinton even
reportedly
Hazard outs members of Congress
Democratic strategists and other major
party figures all said she Harris had
not made herself into a formidable
leader uh Monday article from New York
Times by the way so this is not New York
Post okay this is times times in an
article said member of Commerce
Democratic strategists and other major
party figures like all said Harris had
not made herself into formidable leader
the piece said two Democrats recalled
Clinton privately dismissing Harris
chances of clearing the presidential
primary field because she lacked the
necessary political instincts two
Democrats recalled private conversations
in which former Secretary of Hillary
Clinton state of State Hillary Clinton
lamented that Mrs Harris
could not win because she did not have
the political instincts to clear a
primary field a spokesperson for Clinton
pointed to their strong bond although
the times didn't quote him issuing his
specific denial of Clinton's reported
private thought so there you have it so
this kind of going on so the Border
thing that you're talking about if it
keeps getting worse and worse and it is
it looks like it is 8 000 people a day
no problem then eventually if people
don't want Kamala and Biden to run again
the first thing they're going to do is
they're going to talk about but look at
the border crisis do you understand what
I'm saying so it's it media has a uh uh
Ace in there uh uh it's in the hole Ace
in a whole sleeve to say pinch the bear
yeah don't pinch it yeah they haven't
they have an ace in their shorts to use
that in case something happens to say
bingo go after we need to get somebody
else running go ahead I think you're
absolutely right there's things that are
behind the scenes here the first is
Cuomo has been given the green light
remember who's the Border girl our vice
president
yeah yeah she hasn't been there yet
right I will eventually get there
um the um
so number one he has a green light to do
it number two he is looking for a
Centrist position for his own person you
know Cuomo's not done he doesn't want to
go to Palm Springs and retire you know
Cuomo wants to be relevant and he's he's
got to re-emerge and reinvent himself so
he's coming out with this very moderate
measured position for himself he's been
given the green light to actually say
something like this by the machine and
last week ABC news is saying things like
you know we just ran a poll here at ABC
News
um actually one of them four I think
they're worse off since the start of the
Biden Administration I fell off my chair
and I saw that so there's more things
like that that are going on Hillary's
going out saying these things they're
all trying to do one thing and one thing
only I see the phrase clear a primary
field now they're not trying to clear it
they're trying to build it and they're
trying to build it without the current
president in 24. WoW speaking of Cuomo
are you
um
predicting that Cuomo is going to kind
of give a run in 2024. I I don't think
so but do you think he wants to sit on
the sideline and smeared with doing half
as much as Bill Clinton ever did and yet
he has to sit on the sidelines as the as
the you know hashtag metoo Governor that
got blown out they didn't want that he's
not going to sit there he's got too much
pride and too much
going there
Ben himself and he's coming out here
yeah at the very balance this is a very
balanced honest story well I guess my
question is the southern states were
right ladies other than his own legacy
which is clearly tarnished at this point
yeah what do you think his motivation is
is what is what is political instincts
leading him towards I think the machine
is back there putting these out but what
is Cuomo's he's asking you what's
Andrew's motive I think it's Andrew
here's a way to take a couple steps back
here's something here's something to
come out there and be you know man of
the people a couple steps back what does
he want to accomplish what though I
the guy doesn't want to retire and the
guy's got aspirations aspirations of
being this is purely speculation does he
want to be a pundit does he want to be
involved in the DNC is he running for
something now clearly he's not running
for governor of New York again well he
loves being in front of the camera if
you offered him an opportunity to kind
of make a comeback on MSNBC and be in
front of the camera he'd take it if you
offered him an opportunity to and then
and then
have a platform and the political stage
with the DNC I think he'd take it he
wants to be a deal maker he wants to be
a king maker he wants to be who he was
as the governor of New York and he
doesn't want to go quietly into
retirement so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign